here's another rule in business and a
rule in life if you want to be something
you've got to find people that are
already successful in that field and
you've got to hang around them so I'm
16.
and I went down to this property
investors Network where all the rich
people are hanging out you've got people
worth 100 million pounds 200 million
pounds you've got people with a hundred
properties land developers big farm
Farmers with loads of land and when I
sign in at reception I suddenly feel
really really nervous I suddenly feel
really uncomfortable I start feeling a
bit sick I'm gonna tell you another rule
in business if you want to be very
successful whether that's academically
whether that's in a career in business
you have to get comfortable being
uncomfortable
you have to get used to doing things
that scare you because if you just do
the same comfortable things again and
again and again if you never stretch
yourself you can never grow